imagine a puzzle where the pieces fit
themselves together without inhuman help
these special kinds of puzzles are
actually all around us and a scale we
normally can't see and they put
themselves together in a process called
self-assembly self-assembly occurs when
molecules spontaneously organize into
complex structures like smart puzzle
pieces they are directed to their proper
locations by attractions and repulsions
that result from their electrical
charges magnetic properties in
complementary shapes this means that the
molecules can assemble spontaneously
into ordered rods sheets spheres and
other useful structures that are much
bigger than the individual building
blocks one of these useful structures
self-assembles every time you wash your
hands
soap is made up of molecules called
fatty acids these molecules have a
hydrophilic end that's attracted to
water and a hydrophobic chain that's
attracted to oily substances like grease
and dirt when you wash your hands the
large hydrophobic change cluster around
the particles of grease and dirt leaving
the hydrophilic end sticking out
surrounded by water this self-assembled
dirt trap helps the water pool grease
and dirt off your hands and leaves your
skin squeaky clean
remember that self-assembly organizes
material at a very small scale in fact
the molecules involved in self-assembly
are often measured in units of
nanometers or a billionth of a meter
that's a thousand times smaller than a
human hair
this makes self-assembly especially
useful for nanotechnologies which are
found in everything from computer chips
to electric cars to medical technology
speaking of medical technology one
example is self assembling action is a
new method for getting medicine to the
right places and sick patients a field
known as drug delivery researchers have
found a way to make thin molecular
coatings self-assemble around small
doses of anti-cancer drugs similar to
how soap molecules surround an oily
substance these coatings help the
assembly bind selectively to cancer
cells and release most of the drug when
it gets to those cells where it can do
the most good
this also protects healthy cells from
being attacked by the anti-cancer drug
remember the hydrophobic tails and
hydrophilic ends of the soap molecule
nature uses similar building blocks
called phospholipids in the outer
membrane of each one of your cells these
building blocks contain one hydrophilic
end attached to two hydrophobic tails
these pieces self-assemble into a
violator sort of like a nano scale Ice
Cream Sandwich the center ice cream part
of the bio layer maximizes hydrophobic
interactions between the long tails and
positions of the hydrophilic and cookies
and contact with watery environments
inside or outside the cell the formation
of this phospholipid bilayer keeps
important cellular components like the
nucleus and cytoplasm where they belong
so that they can do what they're
supposed to do where it's supposed to
happen this is one of the many
interacting bits and pieces that come
together to make what's arguably the
most beautiful and intricate example of
self-assembly in nature you
[Music]
you